und das führt mich noch zu einer zweiten
vorbemerkung dass scholz sie haben in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag
eine sicher eine neue offenheit auf die
fahnen geschrieben
ich zitiere mal wir wollen durch mehr
transparenz unsere demokratie stärken
dazu gehört nach unserer auffassung vor
allen dingen natürlich auch die
transparenz gegenüber der presse wir
würden uns deshalb wünschen dass sie
öfter auch in die bundespressekonferenz
kommen als ihre vorgängerin die ihr
bekanntlich nur einmal im jahr vor oder
nach ihrem urlaub kam dann wissen wir
nicht wie oft sie urlaub machen wollen
aber vielleicht können wir das
voneinander trennen und dass sie hier
regelmäßig auch kommen von recht alle
vierteljahre das würden jedenfalls sehr
begrüßen
und es hier dann also auch rede und
antwort zu stehen und wir gehen auch
davon aus dass wir ja auch einen
verbündeten an unserer seite haben wenn
ihr regierungssprecher steffen
hebestreit war ja nicht nur journalisten
sondern auch im vorstand der
bundespressekonferenz vor seinem wechsel
in die politik
die einladung gilt natürlich für alle
kabinettsmitglieder gleichermaßen
das zur vorbemerkung und jetzt haben sie
das was bitteschön schon
dank für die einladung für die
möglichkeit dass wir drei hier
stellvertretend für all die frauen und
männer die in der künftigen
bundesregierung verantwortung übernehmen
werden sprechen können wir wollen den
koalitionsvertrag gibt es nicht einmal
als großen block erläutern sie hatten
wir die gelegenheit längst jede seite zu
lesen und wir haben das bei anderer
gelegenheit getan aber wir freuen uns
dass wir mit ihnen über das was uns
bewegt für die nächste zeit und über
alle diese fragen sprechen können es
geht darum mehr fortschritt zu wagen das
verbindet alle drei parteien dass wir
das jetzt für unser land unternehmen
wollen im sinne der bürgerinnen und
bürger und für eine gute zukunft es geht
auch um ein aufbruch an aufbruch den wir
in einer schwierigen zeit zustande
bringen müssen wo wir immer noch damit
herausgefordert sind die korona pandemie
zu bekämpfen das sind die
rahmenbedingungen unter denen die
regierung jetzt loslegt aber ich will
gerne sagen dass die neugierige
offenheit die wir bei vielen bürgern
bürgern sehen den optimismus den sie
damit verbinden uns auch selbst erfasst
hat und ansonsten freuen wir uns alle
drei auf ihre vielen fragen
dann gehen wir in die fragerunde ich
würde bitten da vielleicht nicht alle
auf dem podium an alle kollegen kennt
sich ganz kurz dann noch mal
vorzustellen wir haben etwa eine stunde
zeit das liegt an zeitplan unser gäste
aber auch an der tatsache dass wir
diesen raum aus hygienischen gründen
dann auch lüften müssen dann hat die
erste frage herr jordan
guten morgen frank jordan sap
ich würde ganz gerne gleich mit nach
außenpolitischen frage einsteigen herr
scholz und zwar wirklich gerne von ihnen
wissen welche außenpolitischen
schwerpunkte
die sie als bundeskanzler zukünftiger
bundeskanzler zunächst setzen wollen
und wohin sie als erstes reisen werden
und daran angeschlossen das weiße haus
hat gestern mitgeteilt dass die usa
keine diplomaten zu den olympischen
spielen schicken werden um die
menschenrechtssituation in china wird
sich deutschland dem anschließen
schönen dank für ihre frage die
schwerpunkte der künftigen regierung
sind ja sehr sorgfältig erläutert in dem
veränderungen die drei parteien
miteinander geschlossen haben es geht
darum dass wir anknüpfen an die
bemühungen die deutschland in den
letzten jahren schon unternommen hat
eine starke sowie in der europäischen
union zu schaffen wir wollen diese
entwicklung weiterer unterstreichen die
zukunft der welt geprägt sein von
ziemlich vielen sehr einflussreich
ländern nicht nur 2 und deshalb ist es
ganz bedeutsam dass in dieser künftigen
welt europa stark
handeln kann meine erste reise wird mich
deshalb auch nach paris führen das hatte
ich sehr früh angekündigt und den werde
ich auch nachkommen und es geht dann
gleich weiter mit all den
zusammenkünften in brüssel die dann ja
auch bald zu dem europäischen rat führen
und vielen treffen mit europäischen
freundinnen und freunden und
gleichzeitig werden wir die konzertante
partnerschaft und unsere zusammenarbeit
auch in der nato unterstreichen es geht
uns darum dass wir uns
einfinden die gemeinschaft der
demokratien um die es uns auch geht wenn
dem präsidenten beiden sehr dankbar dass
er diesen aspekte der internationalen
politik so hervorhebt denn auch wenn wir
uns für eine multilaterale politik
einsetzen ist das immer mit der
vorstellung verbunden dass das etwas
gibt dass einige staaten besonders
verbindet und das ist die vorstellung
von freiheit rechtsstaat demokratie und
menschenrechten und ansonsten ist die
welt ja auch nicht leichter geworden im
hinblick auf das was wir alles machen
werden werden wir uns sorgfältig beraten
und dem internationalen zusammenhang
unsere entscheidungen treffen
danke dann habe ich als nächstes auf der
liste front uns
[Applaus]
kristina dunz redaktions netzwerk
deutschland herr scholz sie haben eher
wenig demütig gesagt sie möchten die
wahl auch in vier jahren gewinnen und
möchten die ampel als ein dauer modell
etablieren und dafür müsste sich jede
partei auch noch verändern
deswegen sehr gerne vielleicht einsatz
von allen drei männern wo ihre
schmerzgrenzen sind und da wir beim
thema männer sind parität im kabinett
hier sitzen sie zu dritt drei männer was
ist das aus ihrer sicht für ein signal
dass keine frau heute abend heute abend
heute mittag mit der kinder wie
ich finde sehr gut dass wir jetzt ein
paritätisches kabinett haben das sehr
verantwortungsvolle aufgaben in der
künftigen bundesregierung auch solche
die etwas zu tun haben mit sicherheit
und äußerer politik das
verteidigungsministerium das
innenministerium das außenministerium
das ministerium für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit von
frauen geleitet werden und das ist
glaube ich auch ein sehr gutes signal
denn hendrik das auf das was alle drei
parteien ein teil der gesellschaft zu
schaffen in der die gleichstellung von
männern und frauen noch endgültig
gelingt dass es eine aufgabe die wir
jetzt vorantreiben wollen und nicht
künftigen jahrzehnten überlassen wollen
und deshalb ist es sehr bedeutsam dass
genau so verantwortungsvolle aufgaben
von dem sehr qualifizierten
ministerinnen und ministern wahrgenommen
werden die wir da vorgesehen haben und
dass frauen und männer zur hälfte in
diesem kabinett vertreten sind ansonsten
wagen wir einen aufbruch einem aufbruch
der die großen herausforderungen dieses
jahrzehnts und weit darüber hinaus
aufgreift und das ist natürlich klar
dass wenn wir zusammenarbeiten und das
gut machen genau das haben wir uns
vorgenommen dass auch ein auftrag ist
bei den nächsten wahlen gemeinsam
wiedergewählt zu werden ich jedenfalls
würde mir das sehr wünschen und die
dinge die wir jetzt anpacken etwa wenn
es darum geht deutschland zu einem
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichen
industrieland zu machen dass weltweit
global wettbewerbsfähig ist und
gleichzeitig klimaneutral wirtschaftet
oder für einen besseren zusammenhalt in
der gesellschaft zu sorgen für mehr
respekt und für mehr liberalität im
miteinander unseres zusammenlebens dann
sind das aufgaben die nicht den ferien
haben zu bewältigen sind sondern dieses
entscheidende jahrzehnten diese
wichtigen 20er jahre insgesamt umfasst
ich kann soviel ich weiss nicht
angefragt ich würde nicht von schmerz
ganzen reden sondern alle parteien
werden in regierungen wachsen sie werden
sich verändern das ist ja völlig klar
aber zum besseren weil man umfassender
denkt weil man lernt seine projekte die
dann ja
parteipolitisch erst einmal aus dem
eigenen milieu heraus als wichtig
erkannt wurden so zu kommunizieren und
umzusetzen dass sie möglichst immer
mehrheitsfähig werden in der
gesellschaft in deutschland und das ist
gut für parteien und das ist der sinn
von politik lässt dich verantwortung für
die wirklichkeit zu übernehmen also ich
sehe keine schmerzgrenzen sondern
wachstumsfragen
ja sehr geehrte frau die uns wir wollen
uns als drei partner nicht begrenzen
sondern erweitern
alle drei kommen mit eigenen
perspektiven und vorstellungen zusammen
wir haben während der letzten wochen
bereits erlebt dass wenn wir uns auf
gemeinsames verständigen dass wir dann
für sehr viel mehr menschen als spd
grüne und fdp gewählt haben orientierung
geben können das empfiehlt sich
fortzusetzen und zu ihrer zweiten frage
dieser koalitionsvertrag enthält ein
klares bekenntnis zur gesellschaftlichen
vielfalt und liberalität und auch viele
vorhaben die beispielsweise den gedanken
der gleichstellung der geschlechter
rechnung tragen und in diesem
koalitionsvertrag sind auch sehr viel
mehr themen enthalten als viele jahre
zuvor die für frauen eine besondere
bedeutung haben und deshalb ist dieser
koalitionsvertrag auch unter
gleichstellungs politischer hinsicht ein
fortschritt
dann bleibe ich in der mitte herr rösler
als nicht
herr scholz tarek herr lindner ich würde
sie gerne bitten noch mal ein bisschen
konkreter über die politik gegenüber
china zu sprechen zum einen war glaube
ich die frage offen geblieben ob
deutschland sich an dem diplomatischen
boykott in die usa angekündigt haben
anschließen wird und sollte und
vielleicht auch noch konkret die frage
wie der weitere umgang mit dem
ausgehandelten investitionsabkommen sein
soll
ist die bundesregierung der auffassung
dass dieses investitionsabkommen
tatsächlich in die tat umgesetzt werden
sollte vielen dank
die welt in der wir jetzt schon leben
und die wir auch in den nächsten jahren
und jahrzehnten kennen lernen werden
wird eine welt sein der als viele
einflussreiche länder gibt
neben den usa und russland die das schon
lange waren ganz sicher china darüber
wird jetzt viel geredet aber nicht nur
dieses eine land sondern viele viele
andere mächtige nationen werden
auftauchen auf der weltbühne viele
staaten das wieder aufgestiegenen asiens
das betrifft korea und japan genauso wie
vietnam und indonesien malaysia indien
und das gilt auch für viele viele andere
staaten gelten in afrika und im süden
amerikas
die welt wird also multipolar und soll
größere aufgabe wird es sein dafür sorge
zu tragen dass es auch eine
multilaterale welt es in der gute
kooperation gelingt und dabei ist es
heute leider immer noch so wie es auch
schon zu den zeiten der entspannungs
politik und der von willy brandt auf den
weg gebrachten ostpolitik der damaligen
sozialliberalen
viele mit dem wir da zu tun haben haben
regierungsformen und regierungen die
vollständig anders ausgerichtet sind als
das was wir selber richtig finden umso
wichtiger ist das
einverständnis haben von gemeinschaft
auch unter dem demokratien in dieser
welt und das finde ich ist das besondere
auch haben der amerikanischen in dem
amerikanischen präsidenten beiden dass
er diesen aspekt auch in seiner politik
neu betont er hat mir ja doch eine
zeitlang die befürchtung dass es aus der
perspektive der damaligen regierung
unter präsident trump egal ist ob man
eine demokratie und ein freundschaftlich
verbunden das land ist oder nicht da ist
jetzt klar dass uns etwas verbindet das
führt nicht dazu dass man keine
unterschiedlichen ansichten und
perspektiven verfolgt sondern das bild
führt ausschließlich dazu dass wir
darüber bescheid wissen und uns dadurch
auch verbunden wissen das hat auch
konsequenzen
im übrigen aber geht es eben um
kooperationen und weil das so ist das
die welt eben nicht und ich hoffe dass
wir es noch einmal anders erleben werden
aber dass sie licht heutzutage und auch
nicht in absehbarer zeit geprägt sein
wird überall von staaten die gleichen
vorstellungen haben wir müssen wir das
hinkriegen über die unterschiede
bescheid zu wissen und trotzdem gut
miteinander auszukommen in der welt
dieses klare kluge verständnis von
politik des äußeren wird die ganze
bundesregierung verfolgen und dazu
gehört auch dass wir über die frage was
im konkreten einzelheiten geschieht in
konkreten situationen sehr sorgfältig
mit uns unter uns und mit den partnern
partner in europa in der welt beraten
und das nicht auf pressekonferenzen tun
den stil werden sie nicht kennen lernen
dann habe ich zwei fragen die ich zu
lassen möchte
nehmt das was olaf scholz gesagt hat er
gesagt dass seine erste reise nach paris
führen wird und wir werden alle das
ganze kabinett ja jetzt in den nächsten
tagen und wochen vor allem mit den
europäischen partnerländern und partnern
und der europäischen kommission das
gespräch suchen sind solche gespräche
leben zu führen und auch die
zusammenarbeit in europa nicht nur
rhetorisch zu beschreiben sondern eben
tatsächlich voranzubringen heißt eben
dass deutschland
finanz- wirtschafts- und außenpolitisch
einrückt in eine christian lindner hat
das mal gesagt die eine führungsrolle
das heißt also die verantwortung
wahrnehmen ohne gross manager
aufzutreten und ich glaube das gilt dann
für alle politikfelder was das
verhältnis zu china im besonderen angeht
wird man immer wieder sich genau
anschauen müssen wo
kooperationen oder übernahmen von firmen
im europäischen und deutschen interesse
sind wo sie aber auch manchmal nicht im
deutschen oder europäischen interesse
sind so dass die staatliche souveränität
von der olaf scholz gesprochen hat auch
einfluss auf die wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen beziehungsweise die
beziehung zwischen firmen oder
unternehmen haben kann
diese koalition hat sich vorgenommen die
beziehungen zur volksrepublik china
weiter zu entwickeln dabei wird auch
weiterhin die besondere rolle des
chinesischen binnenmarkt für die
deutsche wirtschaft berücksichtigt
werden auf der anderen seite haben wir
uns vorgenommen auf
der weltbühne auch einen einsatz zu
zeigen für menschenrechte die achtung
des völkerrechts und multilateralismus
deshalb wird bei weiter entwickelten
beziehungen zur volksrepublik china auch
diese frage immer offene austausch eine
rolle spielen wichtig für uns und das an
den koalitionsvertrag ja dargelegt ist
dass die bilateralen beziehungen zur
volksrepublik china aus einer
europäischen und transatlantischen
perspektive weiterentwickelt werden
sollen es kann also nicht nur um die
bilateralen beziehungen zwischen
bundesrepublik deutschland und
volksrepublik china gehen sondern die
wartung einer europäischen perspektive
auf die zusammenarbeit mit dieser diesem
wichtigen spieler auf der weltbühne
dann habe ich zwei fragen an sie herrn
lindner ich faste mal zusammen herr
buchsteiner
fragt was wird ihr erstes inhaltliches
vorhaben im bmf über den
nachtragshaushalt hinaus seien und wie
werden sie das haus strukturell und
personell
umbauen und dann hatte ich noch eine
zweite frage
und zwar von britta buchholz zdf frage
an den bundesfinanzminister der
mindestlohn sei steigend bürgergeld
stadt hat hier eine kindergrundsicherung
noch weiteres wie wollen sie all diese
pläne gegenfinanziert vielen dank für
die beiden fragen
buchsteiner hat gefragt nach den ersten
vorhaben des neuen bundesministers der
finanzen
die werden geprägt sein durch den
nachtragshaushalt
2021 und über alle weiteren inhaltlichen
fragen wird dann danach entschieden
werden das werde ich nicht tun bevor ich
überhaupt das haus betreten habe und
frau buchholz wir haben klare
leitplanken beschrieben wir wollen ab
2023 die schuldenbremse des
grundgesetzes wieder einhalten auf der
anderen seite wollen wir verzichten auf
höhere
steuerbelastungen erhöhung der
steuersätze innerhalb dieser leitplanken
werden wir die vorhaben die die
koalition sich aufgegeben hat im
koalitionsvertrag finanzieren und in
eine
finanzielle
prioritäten folge bringen wo das ist
bereits durch festlegungen im
koalitionsvertrag erfolgt ist
dann hab ich als nächstes auf der liste
ich wechseln nach vorne verknüpft
er herrscht häufig sie haben die
transatlantischen beziehungen betont
haben sie sich mit so beiden bereits
abgestimmt haben gespräche stattgefunden
bevor er ja mit wladimir putin virtuell
über die situation an der ukrainischen
grenze spricht wie weit sind sie da es
auf eine linie und wo sehen sie die
dringendste kursänderung in der
deutschen außenpolitik unter einer
regierung schaue
ich habe mit präsident beiden zusammen
mit frau merkel gesprochen als wir
versammelt waren zu den großen
internationalen treffen vor einiger zeit
und natürlich finden jetzt zwischen der
deutschen regierung und der
amerikanischen regierung und auch den
regierungschefs der wichtigsten länder
enge absprachen stadt auch im hinblick
auf das gespräch das die angesprochen
haben zwischen beiden im putin
ist heute habe ich darüber auch mit der
kanzlerin nicht unmittelbar abgestimmt
ich hoffe dass ich morgen zum
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt werde und dann werde
ich auch entsprechend agieren
darf ich ja präsent
wo sehen sie die notwendigkeit einer
kursänderung der deutschen außenpolitik
die deutsche außenpolitik gibt es
kontinuitäten und die transatlantische
partnerschaft zwischen deutschland und
den usa und in europa und den usa ist
einer der ganz wichtigen aspekte und die
enge zusammenarbeit mit den usa auch das
habe ich bereits ausgeführt bei den
früheren fragen das wird auch die
politik in zukunft bestimmen
nächste frage herr fischer
das jetzt michael fischer dpa ich würde
auch gerne für außenpolitik noch mal
fragen zum thema ukraine herr scholz der
russische truppenaufmarsch
an der ukrainischen grenze hat dafür
sehr viel sehr viel besorgnis ausgelöst
ich würde interessieren ob sie die noch
ausstehende inbetriebnahme von dort zwei
als ein instrument sehen um druck
auszuüben auf russland mit blick auf die
ukraine und her habe ich in sie waren ja
im wahlkampf in der ukraine sie waren
dort an der frontlinie haben sich selbst
ein bild gemacht und haben damals
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
befürwortet mich würde interessieren ob
sie das immer noch als eine option sehen
um
keine den rücken zu stärken in diesem
konflikt
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
setzten die beachtung von prinzipien
voraus über die wir uns verständigt
haben in langen prozessen die auch
ausfluss der entspannungs politik der
70er und 80er jahre gewesen sind bis
heute fortwirken dazu gehört die
unverletzlichkeit unverletzbarkeit der
grenzen das ist ganz ganz wichtig dass
niemand in geschichtsbüchern wälzt und
ganz neu ziehen zu können und natürlich
gucken wir aus deutschland heraus
genauso wie alle anderen in europa und
die usa und viele andere sehr besorgt
auf die truppenbewegungen die wir an der
ukrainischen grenze sehen deshalb muss
ganz ganz klar sein dass das seine
inakzeptable situation wäre wenn sich
wenn da eine bedrohung im stunde für die
ukraine ist dass es da auch klarheit
gibt unter all denjenigen die sich in
dieser frage miteinander besprechen das
wird präsident beiden sicherlich in
seinem gespräch zum ausdruck bringen und
das ist die haltung die auch die
europäische union und wir gemeinsam zu
diesem thema haben und deshalb sind wir
sehr sehr klar
dass sich in der ukraine war war die
bedrohungssituation
eine andere und doch vergleichbar es war
kurz nach dem ist einen größeren
truppenaufmarsch im norden der ukraine
gegeben hat aber damals an sommers war
diese massive truppen die truppen
massierung nicht da trotzdem war es ein
heißer konflikt leute sind täglich oder
wöchentlich gestorben vor diesem
hintergrund habe ich das ist meine
unveränderte persönliche meinung nicht
verstanden wieso deutschland sanitär
hilfe leistet aber nicht dazu beiträgt
die ukrainischen menschen so zu schützen
dass sie nicht erst die füße
weggesprengt bekommen da handelte sich
aber um waffensysteme die drohungen die
landminen oder andere sprengsätze
transportieren über die grenze dass die
nicht landen können und ihre tödliche
fracht an den hinterhöfen abwerfen das
sind also ich hatte damals defensiv
sachenbacher und gesagt das sind keine
waffensysteme die geeignet wären jetzt
einen wirklich heißen
aggressions konflikt zu verhindern
das muss man also sauber trennen
voneinander und was jetzt die situation
in der ukraine angeht so muss die lösung
der diplomatischen folgen also die ganze
anstrengung europas muss darauf
gerichtet werden die bestehenden formate
wieder zu reaktivieren und dafür zu
sorgen das ist eben nicht zu einem noch
heißeren aggressiven kriegerischen
konflikt wird es gibt ja diese
auseinandersetzung dort aber das was
droht ist eben noch eine ganz andere
dimension gehen mit aller kraft
verhindert werden muss
dann hat mich als nächsten sie kollege
bitte daran etwas kz df eine frage an
den lippen alles so ein bisschen blöd
entschuldigung die neue regierung will
eine allgemeine impfpflicht angesichts
der code kommt emi einführen februar
märz
mit welchen mitteln sollen sie eine
solche pflicht durchsetzen da ja ein
nicht gerade kleiner teil der
bevölkerung sich einfach nicht impfen
lassen will und wie überzeugen sie
diejenigen in ihrer partei ihre
parteifreunde die strikt gegen eine
solche pflicht sind
vielen dank für ihre frage die
einführung einer allgemeinen gesetzlich
festgelegten impfpflicht ist kein
vorhaben der ampel koalition es gibt die
verabredung dass aus der mitte des
deutschen bundestages sogenannte
gruppenanträge
fraktionsübergreifend erarbeitet werden
und dann werden die mitglieder des
deutschen bundestages in einer offenen
debatte über diese gruppen anträge
entscheiden wir als freie demokraten
werden kein einheitliches abstimmungs
und meinungsbild in unserer fraktion
herstellen sondern es in die ethische
abwägung der mitglieder unserer fraktion
stellen ob sie eine allgemeine
impfpflicht zustimmen darüber kann man
zur stunde gar noch nichts weiteres
sagen da ja auch keine gruppen anträge
vorliegen und man deshalb sich zu
einzelnen varianten einer möglichen
allgemeinen in pflicht momentan noch gar
nicht positionieren kann
man ergänzen dann lange bittet
davor dass danke stefan lange augsburger
allgemeine auch eine frage zu kroner
bitte an alle drei es gab am wochenende
die sogenannten fackel aufmärsche das
wurde vielfach bedeutet dass es da
hingedeutet dass der protest gegen die
kohlepolitik
eskalieren würde oder eskaliert das
heißt auch ihre analyse und wenn ja was
ist die politische antwort danke
die mehrheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
unterstützt die korona politik der
gegenwärtigen bundesregierung wird
genauso die krone politik der künftigen
bundesregierung unterstützen wir müssen
alles dafür tun dass wir die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger schützen
können und das wird nur gelingen wenn
sich möglichst viele impfen lassen wir
haben eine sehr hohe impfquoten man ein
ganz großer teil der deutschen
bevölkerung
bereits zweimal geimpft sehr viele haben
sich mindestens einmal impfen lassen und
jetzt sind millionen dabei sich eine
auffrischungsimpfung zu holen was alles
notwendig ist gerade deshalb haben wir
schon bevor wir als regierung morgen
zusammen loslegen werden auf den weg
gebracht dass es einen neuen krisenstab
gibt er von general breuer geleitet wird
um genau das zu organisieren noch viele
millionen zusätzliche erstimpfung und
zweiter und auffrischungsimpfung wenn
das alles zusammen seitdem wir die
empfehlung haben dass alle über 18
jährigen auch eine auffrischungsimpfung
bekommen können mit erst und
auffrischungsimpfung 30 millionen werden
dann ist das etwas was dazu beitragen
kann die jetzt sichtbare vierte welle zu
brechen und ganz klar heißt das auch
dass wir einschränkungen brauchen
insbesondere für diejenigen die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen dann darüber
gibt es gar keinen zweifel man kann das
ganz konkret sehen das heute uns alle
beeinträchtigende infektionsgeschehen
rührt von den ungeimpften her viele von
denen sind auch selbst bedroht denn die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie sich
infizieren lassen dass sie infiziert
werden ist sehr sehr hoch und deshalb
ist es auch sehr wahrscheinlich dass ein
teil davon erkranken wird und ein
weiterer teil davon auf den
intensivstationen um das eigene leben
bringen wird müssen und um genau das zu
verhindern ist es so wichtig dass wir
mit den möglichkeiten die wir auch in
der ganzen zeit ergriffen haben um die
ausbreitung desinfektion des geschehens
zu verhindern auch wieder arbeiten
allerdings präzise eingesetzt den
hinblick auf diejenigen die dafür auch
die ursache setzen nämlich die
ungeimpften das ist die 2g regelung dass
es zwei gpus was wir jetzt haben im
handel in restaurants und öffentlichen
veranstaltung für viele zusammenkommen
können zum beispiel und deshalb ist auch
das etwas das ganz ganz bedeutsam ist im
übrigen
muss man ganz klar sagen die
gesellschaft ist eben nicht gespalten
sondern überwiegend einer meinung mit
lassen das was zu tun ist und dass es
auch in die richtung gehen muss die ich
eben beschrieben habe dass man da über
einzelne maßnahmen diskutieren kann
gehört dazu aber das grundverständnis
ist er doch eher so und natürlich gibt
es einige die anderer meinung sind dass
es in ordnung und gibt es von diesen
wieder ein teil des
aggressiv agiert davon darf aber die
ganze gesellschaft sich nicht anstecken
lassen sondern wir müssen mit aller
entschiedenheit
zurückweisen dass das gewalttätige und
gewalt
inszenierende
veranstaltungen gibt und wenn dann eine
fackel aufzüge vor dem haus einer
gesundheitsministerin stattfinden dann
ist das als bedrohung gemeint das ist
nicht nur eine meinungsäußerung und wir
als demokraten demokraten weisen das
entschieden zurück und ich glaube dass
das eine haltung die nicht nur diese
regierung ein sondern die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes
die notwendigkeit das für eine erhöhte
impfquote bekommen dass menschen sich
also impfen lassen ist unbestreitbar und
sie das impfen ist der weg wieder zu
einer offenen freien gesellschaft mit
möglichst wenig einschränkungen
deswegen muss politik in der
verantwortung für das land und für die
freiheit die notwendigen maßnahmen
ergreifen und das werden wir auch tun
die
sie sich bisher nicht haben impfen
lassen haben denke ich sehr
unterschiedliche gründe dafür teilweise
ist es vielleicht einfach nur die
sprachliche barriere nicht erreicht
worden zu sein nicht informiert zu sein
ist mögen berechtigte sorgen vor
gesundheitlichen nachwirkungen haben
geben an der stelle das ist alles
hinzunehmen zu akzeptieren
beziehungsweise als ernstzunehmende
argumente zu gewichten auf dauer können
sie nicht bestand haben weil wir wie
gesagt eine freiheitliche offene form
des zusammenlebens nur herstellen können
wenn wir uns in großer anzahl
impfen lassen
problematisch wird es da wo aus den
unterschiedlichen gründen eine
ideologische bewegung entsteht die sich
nicht mit der frage des impfens
auseinandersetzt sondern dann die
staatlichkeit selbst die offene
demokratie die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung und ihre
repräsentanten nicht mehr akzeptiert
oder gar angreift und deswegen muss man
auch für diejenigen die sich bisher
nicht haben impfen lassen die
notwendigkeit der differenzierung
einfordern und die bitte kann man nur
äußern dass aber auch ein auftrag für
uns als kommende regierung nicht aus
einer skepsis gegen das impfen zu einer
ideologischen ablehnung von
demokratischen werten und pflichten am
ende zu kommen das ist nicht das gleiche
wir werden deswegen als politikerinnen
und politiker als regierung die aufgabe
haben weiter überzeugungsarbeit zu
leisten
für diejenigen die sich überzeugen
lassen können oder wollen
gleichzeitig wie olaf scholz es gesagt
hat sehr deutlich klar machen wo die
grenzen überschritten sind und wo aus
fachfragen oder fach nachfragen
eine
verschwörungstheorie tische sich
vermenge mit anderen ideologischen
gefährlichen formen politische fronten
bildung entsteht da muss dann
tatsächlich die politik auch aus
innenpolitischer und demokratischer
sicht handeln und die bedrohung von
ministerin ministern von repräsentanten
des staates die ja ihre aufgabe für die
gesellschaft nachkommen ist nicht in
keinster weise akzeptabel
ja meine damen und herren ich muss
nicht die richtigen aspekte der beiden
vorredner
wiederholen ich will nur unterstreichen
dass wir uns alle gemeinsam entschieden
einschüchterungsversuchen gegenüber
staatlichen verantwortungsträgern
entgegenstellen unser staat ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie
alle diejenigen die die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung aus welcher
veranlassung auch immer in frage stellen
müssen sich sicher sein dass dieser
staat das nicht hinnehmen wird
wir haben als ampelkoalition bereits vor
dem eintritt in regierungsverantwortung
beiträge geleistet zur befriedung
gesellschaftlicher konflikte
ein geäußerter kritikpunkt war in der
vergangenheit ja dass viele
grundrechtssensiblen entscheidungen ohne
einbeziehung der parlamente getroffen
werden würden das hat die neue
parlamentsmehrheit korrigiert
grundrechtseingriffe erfolgen nun auf
der basis von parlaments gesetzen im
bund und
gegebenenfalls notwendigen weiteren
maßnahmen werden die länder legislativen
mit einbezogen diese
parlamentarisierung der pandemie
bekämpfung ist auch ein beitrag dazu
gesellschaftliche konflikte zu befrieden
weil nämlich auch die gegnerinnen und
gegner einzelner maßnahmen erkennen dass
in öffentlicher sitzung
das für und das wieder bei maßnahmen
diskutiert wird und zum anderen dass die
materielle pandemie politik angeht kann
jeder sehen dass die neue mehrheit im
bundestag wie auch die neue
bundesregierung mit größter konsequenz
die gesundheitlichen risiken gekämpft
dass auch operative mängel abgestellt
werden
das ist mir dass wir es uns auf der
anderen seite aber auch nicht leicht
machen bei der schliessung und
stilllegung des gesellschaftlichen
lebens wir verbinden also neu die
unbedingte notwendigkeit
konsequenten gesundheitsschutzes mit der
sensibilität auch der sozialen kosten
der pandemie bekämpfung und auch das ist
ein beitrag dazu
bedenken und kritik an der pandemie
politik aufzunehmen ohne in der
entschlossenheit diese gesundheitskrise
zu bewältigen nachzugeben
dann hab ich wechsele ich einmal nach
rechts die nächste frage stellen ist
daher gewarnt
jan hildebrand vom handelsblatt
eine frage an herrn scholz was sind denn
ihre erwartungen an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
kommenden donnerstag sie sehe dann
erstmals als kanzler mit führen werden
und an den künftigen
bundesfinanzminister herlind nach vor
dem hintergrund der vierten corona bälle
und der verschärfung die wir jetzt sehen
und einschränkung für die wirtschaft
gilt ihre aussage noch dass die 100
milliarden neuverschuldung die ihr
vorgänger er stolz geplant hat für
kommendes jahr dass sie die vier
auskömmlich und ausreichend halten danke
doch paris
da gibt es eine seite lang verabredete
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten konferenz mit
gemeinsamen gespräch mit der kommenden
bundesregierung ich glaube das wichtige
wird sein dass man auch mal in dieser
neuen konstellation zusammen kommt wir
hatten wir zwar eine phase in der
gewissermassen alte und neue regierung
mit am tisch saßen die neue
repräsentiert durch mich und das glaube
ich ist jetzt eine situation wo dann
mehrere minister und minister auch die
beiden hier anwesenden dabei sind ich
glaube das ist erstmal gut denn wir
wollen ja die nächsten jahre sehr gut
zusammenarbeiten mit dem
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten und den
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeistern
und dann ist es so dass wir
da eine tagesordnung haben wo es um
viele einzelpunkte geht die laufendes
geschäft umfassen das will ich jetzt
aber nicht im einzelnen erläutern und
natürlich auch immer über das reden
werden was uns alle umtreibt die frage
der korona pandemie und was wir
gemeinsam unternehmen wollen letzte
woche sind da sehr weitreichende
beschlüsse gefasst worden die jetzt
überall umgesetzt werden in den ländern
das finde ich auch sehr sehr wichtig und
das findet statt und gleichzeitig findet
gerade in diesem augenblick im deutschen
bundestag auf eine sehr kurze beratung
statt um die gesetzlichen anpassungen
vorzunehmen die sich aus dem gespräch
mit dem ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten ergeben und in dem
spiel werden wir weiter
hildebrandt die
finanzplanung von olaf scholz war
vorausschauend
sie enthält auch reserven für
unvorhergesehenes
während dieser pandemie
deshalb ist mit dem wissen von heute dem
siebten dezember 2021 die finanzplanung
für das kommende jahr unverändert
auskömmlich die künftige bundesregierung
beabsichtigt aber dem deutschen
bundestag mit dem
der zweite nachtragshaushalt
vorzuschlagen
in diesem haus als ja nicht in anspruch
genommene kreditermächtigungen
in die folgejahre zu übernehmen da die
wirtschaftliche erholung nach der
pandemie bedingten rezession nicht in
der weise erfolgt ist wie wir uns das
wünschen
außerdem ist zu befürchten dass aufgrund
der pandemie viele notwendige maßnahmen
die den klimaschutz und der
transformation von wirtschaft
gesellschaft und staat gedient hätten
nicht vorgenommen werden konnten weshalb
wir unter strikter beachtung betrachtung
und beachtung dessen was die verfassung
erlaubt auch dafür mit künftig nutzen
möchten
denn nur als zwischenstand ich hab noch
weit über 20 fragen die werden wir nicht
abarbeiten können das wollte ich nur
schon mal dazwischen sagen es waren
schließlich auch mal die frageliste die
nächste frage frau kollegin gleich in
der serbe reihe her
julius nicht öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk ein rest meiner frage an herrn
schutz wochen würden die menschen in
europa merken dass angela merkel weg ist
und dass sie der neue bundeskanzler sind
deutschland hat eine große kontinuität
in der europapolitik es gibt einen sehr
umfassenden konsens darüber dass wir als
land uns verantwortlich fühlen für den
weiteren fortschritt in der europäischen
union und das ist wichtig dass das nicht
nur für die regierung gilt sondern auch
jedenfalls für die meisten
oppositionsparteien
die jetzt dann diese politik begleiten
werden meine sicht auf diese frage ist
immer gewesen deutschlands ein sehr
großes land mit einer sehr großen
bevölkerung an der großen
wirtschaftskraft mitten in europa bei
uns ist es wichtig dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger das parlament und die
regierung sich verpflichtet für den
fortschritt in europa möglich zu machen
wir können nicht so agieren wie es
vielleicht der eine oder die andere ab
und zu mal tut im eigenen land heftig
auftreten das bisschen gegen brüssel
wettern dann dort ganz gute kompromisse
machen und wieder zurück kommen und
sagen ist aber alles gut geworden
sondern wir müssen von vornherein dafür
sorgen dass das gut werden ein teil
unserer nationalen politik ist im
gemeinschaftlichen interesse europas das
wird zu sein und ansonsten
ist es so dass die meisten mich ja doch
gut einschätzen können und auch damit
die künftige regierung wir haben agiert
als europa jetzt zusammenstehen musste
mit der bekämpfung der pandemie ist es
eine solidarische antwort auf diese
krise gewesen auch mit dem europäischen
wiederaufbau formen und ich glaube dass
das genügend zeichen ist um zu verstehen
was wir in der zukunft machen werden
dann habe ich eine online frage von
susanne landwehr von der deutsche
verkehrs zeitung das
bundesverkehrsministerium wird sich
künftig um das digitale kümmern aus
welchen ministerien werden welche
abteilungen in das en-v eingegliedert
ich glaube dass man sagen kann dass das
alles gut geordnet sein wird
dann habe ich als nächste frage stellen
frau böhme ganz hinten das ist mit dem
mikro
privaten wie vom luxemburger wort herr
scholz sie werden ja in sehr naher
zukunft sicher ihre erste
regierungserklärung
handeln
ihre vorgängerin war in der disziplin
die das ja beinhaltet nämlich regieren
zu erklären nicht besonders ambitioniert
und oft auch nicht besonders erfolgreich
wie wollen sie das denn an stellen das
dann auch wirklich verstanden wird
was sie regierend erreichen wollen
ob ich mich dem urteil
frau merkel anschließen möchte weiß ich
nicht nein ich weiß dass ich ihn nicht
zustimme das will ich ganz klar dazu
sagen die haben zu sehr entscheidenden
fragen der deutschen politik gesprochen
und damit auch wieder gegeben dass die
jeweils von ihr geführte regierung sich
in diesen fragen als gemeinsame
strategie zurechtgelegt und ansonsten
hat jeder seinen eigenen stil auch ich
werde so reden wie ich es tue wie die
meisten mich kenne kennen und ich werde
dabei das repräsentieren was wir uns an
programm und vorhaben gegeben haben mit
dem heute unterzeichneten vertrag über
die bildung einer regierung mehr
fortschritt wagen steht da drauf und der
fortschritt und das mit dem mond dazu
haben das notwendige tun zu tun damit
die zwanziger jahre gut werden da wird
sicher sichtbar werden als teil dessen
was wir uns vorgenommen haben auch in
der regierungserklärung
dann wechsle ich nochmal in die mitte
herr ismaik
ist der tagesspiegel eine oder zwei kurz
ertrag an herrn lindner einheiten und
dann muss ich die verknüpfen
wer sie herrn katzer als
haushaltsstaatssekretär behalten und wie
machen sie das eigentlich mit der
amtsübergabe mit herrn scholz der ja
auch noch das kanzleramt morgen
übernehmen muss und dann herrn scholz
eine ganz kurze frage es gibt einen
bericht dass die mit präsident lee schon
im oktober glaub ich gesprochen haben
immer eine zusicherung des kurses der
kanzlerin in sachen china politik
zugesichert haben die gesagt hätten sie
würden ihre koalitionspartner dabei in
schach halten
ich habe kein bilaterales gespräch
geführt über das ich in der zeitung
gelesen habe
erstmalig werde über die frage der
beamteten
staatssekretäre und
weiterer organisatorischer maßnahmen im
haus erst dann die öffentlichkeit
informieren wenn ich im haus bin und
auch gespräche geführt habe und zum
anderen sind
wir verabredet für donnerstagmittag
nachdem der designierte bundeskanzler im
bundeskanzleramt gewesen ist
dann der hilfsmittel
scholz allerdings von bloomberg ich muss
noch mal ganz kurz zurück kommt zum
thema ukraine und nord stream 2
da sagten sie ja eben dass es
inakzeptabel wäre wenn die ukraine
bedroht würde aber ich mein faktisch
kann man ja sagen das ist ja schon
eigentlich der zustand jetzt also wenn
diesen
panzereinheiten aufgefahren sind
russische an der grenze usa warten ja
jetzt dass deutschland daher dass nosql
zwei projekt auch als druckmittel
einsetzt und möglicherweise stoppt und
verweist auf eine absprache die noch die
kanzlerin merkel mit den beiden
getroffen hat und danach soll das
projekt gestoppt als putin gas als waffe
einsetzt fühlen sie sich noch weiter an
diese vereinbarungen gebunden
und sehen sie angesichts der derzeitigen
lage in der ukraine
inwieweit bestand des einsatzes von gas
als waffe erfüllt
wir verfolgen die situation in der
ukraine
sehr sehr
sorgfältig und wir wissen das haben wir
hier schon miteinander besprochen dass
das gerade eine sehr sehr ernste lage
ist deshalb ist auch klar dass der
unmissverständlich auf dem bestehen was
für uns alle wichtig ist der
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen und das
hat konsequenzen wir setzen weiter
darauf dass das normandie format wieder
seine wirkung entfalten kann denn nur im
gespräch miteinander und entlang dieser
prinzipien kann es gelingen eine bessere
situation dort zu erreichen und
ansonsten haben wir uns sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass
klar ist dass die ukraine ein
transitland für gast bleibt wir haben
selbst mit einem eigenen
bevollmächtigten sorge dafür getragen
dass die verträge verlängert werden und
wir werden das auch weiter tun da gelten
eigentlich verstärkungen die wir in
dieser hinsicht gefunden haben und bitte
ihr auch überall berichtet wurden
nachfrage ganz kurz noch mal an eine
harte partie sieht das ja wesentlich
kritischer mit nord stream 2 wenn sie
auch noch mal in ihre meinung zu dem
thema sagen
was stimmt zwar ist nicht genehmigt und
die überprüfung der
vorgaben der europäischen wieder
deutschen dauert an und wir werden
entlang des raumes der überprüfung
sicherlich auch noch mal politisch
darüber reden wie die außenpolitische
situation
in der ukraine
und die europäische
möglichkeit die eskalierend zu wirken
zusammengebracht werden können
ich habe noch eine frage online klaus
remme fragt
nachdem herr scholz jetzt zweimal nicht
geantwortet hat wird sich deutschland
einem diplomatischen boykott der
winterspiele anschließen
die neue bundesregierung tritt morgen
zusammen wir finden dass es wichtig ist
dass man alles dafür tut dass die welt
international zusammenarbeitet und alle
maßnahmen die man jeweils ergreift
müssen sorgfältig abgewogen werden in
einer welt die zusammenarbeit muss gibt
es auch darum dass man die signale der
zusammenarbeit nutzt
dann habe ich als nächsten frage stelle
herrn rinke
pardon
jetzt
schaut sie haben eben die zusammenarbeit
in europa betont und herr beck die enge
abstimmung in den nächsten tagen ich
hätte ganz gern auf den ost west
konflikt in der eu über
rechtsstaatlichkeit gesprochen also
viele sagen ja der nord süd konflikt ist
überwunden jetzt ist die größte gefahr
er eine spaltung ost west teilen sie
diese einschätzung und ich hätte ganz
gern die frage an alle drei gestellt wie
sollte man künftig mit polen und ungarn
umgehen einen härteren kurs bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit fahren seitens der
eu oder stärker auf diese länder zu
gehen danke
deutschland ist ich hab eben darauf
schon abgehoben inland mitten in europa
wir sind nicht dazu aufgerufen am rande
zu stehen und schlecht oder gut gelaunte
kommentare abzugeben sondern wir sind
für das miteinander in europa um das
gelingen des fortschritts verantwortlich
und deshalb betrachten wir und ich es
als wichtigste aufgabe dafür zu sorgen
dass es solche spaltung wie sie die
skizzieren als möglichkeit nicht geben
wird bei der nord süd noch ist ost
sondern dass wir alle gemeinsam zusammen
arbeiten in der europäischen union und
was die nachbarschaft zu polen betrifft
würde ihn sehr gerne und sehr
ausdrücklich sagen dass es für uns ganz
wichtig ist diese nachbarschaft
freundschaftlich zu gestalten wollen
dass eine große nation eine demokratie
und ich bin sehr froh dass
holen teil unserer gemeinsamen
europäischen union ist und wir dort
miteinander über gemeinsame fragen uns
abstimmen und auch manchmal ringen
können und unsere zukunft gemeinsam
voran dass wir die fragen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit sehr klar beurteilen
ist richtig und notwendig denn das führt
uns in europa auch zusammen dass wir
eine union sind von staaten die sich zur
rechtsstaatlichkeit und freiheitliche
demokratie bekennen und
selbstverständlich muss das dann auch
gelingen dass das überall in europa dem
gleichem maße der fall ist und darum
geht es auch bei der politik der
nächsten zeit und der nächsten jahre ich
war sehr froh dass mich der polnische
ministerpräsident noch vor der wahl der
neuen bundesregierung besucht hat und
ich bedingung ein sehr gutes gespräch
führen konnte und wir werden die
gespräche auch fortführen ich hoffe auch
sehr schnell in polen und das wird dann
auch die grundlage dafür sein können
dass wir es schaffen zu gemeinsam
erkenntnissen zu kommen der rechtsstaat
wie gesagt ist etwas das zu europa dazu
gehört und dass uns miteinander ausmacht
dann die nächste fahrt erklären
sie haben recht gering
die historische dimension
dass europa nicht nur ein westliches
europa ist sondern die aussöhnung auf
dem kontinent über die europäische union
erfolgt hat olaf scholz angesprochen und
die muss verpflichtung sein für das
mittelland dass wir ihn mal sind europa
insofern darf es da keine
leichtfertigkeit geben ich würde
zweitens sagen dass wenn man immer von
den osteuropäischen staaten von polen
von ungarn redet man der situation in
diesen ländern unrecht tut es gibt
gerade in polen eine
starke demokratische
alleine eine starke bewegung für eine
andere politik
dessen ungeachtet
gilt das
historische werk eben auf der grundlage
von rechtsstaatlichkeit durchzuführen
und rechtsstaatlichkeit dann auch
einzufordern ist die aufgabe der
europäischen kommission und sie sollte
dann auch von deutschland in der
hinsicht unterstützt werden
ich muss da nichts hinzufügen vielen
dank
der bärtige
eine frage von einer ganzen von der von
ein totales lindner
die inflationsrate ist jetzt auf dem
höchsten niveau seit
1992 wie bewerten sie die
zukünftige finanzminister die
inflationsrisiken in der in der
deutschen wirtschaft und manche
politiker haben zum die besorgnis zum
ausdruck gebracht
dass der schuldenstand bei vielen
europäischen ländern zu schnell in der
pandemie gewachsen ist was ist ihre
meinung dazu
künftige bundesregierung wird in der
langjährigen kontinuität verbleiben und
deshalb für
stabilität
eintreten wir beobachten die
geldentwertung
mit großer aufmerksamkeit
fraglos hat sich durch die pandemie
eine reihe haben sich eine reihe von
sondereffekten verbunden nun wird man
die
entwicklung in den nächsten jahren
beobachten müssen die fiskalpolitik der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird darauf
natürlich rücksicht nehmen wir sehen
insbesondere auch die notenbankpolitik
in diesem
zusammenhang hier
sind ja entscheidungen unsere
unabhängigen europäischen zentralbank
angekündigt für den dezember die
entwicklung der schulden in der
europäischen wirtschafts und
währungsunion
hat sich aufgrund der pandemie stark
erhöht
deshalb haben wir eine sensibilität eine
situation der fiskalischen dominanz auch
zukünftig zu vermeiden
notenbank muss in der lage sein auf die
geld entwicklung auch mit ihren
instrumenten zu antworten aus diesem
grund empfiehlt sich dass die
wirtschafts und währungsunion
weiter sich dem stabilitäts- gedanken in
verbindung mit bemühungen um wachstum
und investitionen verpflichtet und in
diesem sinne wird die künftige
bundesregierung sich auch einbringen in
das gespräch über den review der fiskus
im nächsten jahr
dann habe ich eine frage online von
benjamin wehrmann clean energy war herr
harbeck der beschleunigte ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie wird wohl das
kernthema ihrer amtszeit werden welche
sofortmaßnahmen vielleicht innerhalb der
ersten 100 tage wollen sie anstoßen um
das feld für die schnelle errichtung von
windkraft und solaranlagen zu bereiten
wenn wir
ein land wie deutschland mit seiner
großen industriellen infrastruktur mit
seinem grünen im mittelstand
klimaneutral machen wollen dann ist das
eine enorme herausforderung und vier
neutral bedeutet natürlich unter den
bedingungen von wohlstand und wachstum
die produktion von erneuerbaren energien
in großem ausmaß und in großer menge und
das ganze ein großer geschwindigkeit ich
will also an der stelle sagen dass bei
allen sonntagsreden die es immer gibt
für mehr klimaschutz und irgendwie sind
alle für erneuerbare energien das nicht
ohne zumutungen zu haben sein wird das
ist mir persönlich und allen die den
koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben und
geschrieben haben wohl bewusst in der
tat wenn sie sagen es wird ein zentrales
thema dieser amtszeit werden so liebe
ich es auch so befürchtete es auch weil
es eben nicht leicht zu haben sein wird
wir werden viel miteinander als land als
gesellschaft zu diskutieren haben wenn
wir diese ziele umsetzen wollen und das
ist ein langstreckenlauf hier haben wir
uns das ziel gesetzt den anteil der
erneuerbaren energien in den nächsten
jetzt eigentlich nur noch acht jahren
auf 80 prozent zu erhöhen das ist die
drei- bis vierfache
ausbaugeschwindigkeit die wir bisher
hatten
alle sparten tv anschauen und offshore
wind betreffend und das wird eine große
kraftanstrengung seien die
gesellschaftliche debatte
notwendig erforderlich macht die aber
natürlich auch eine große anforderung an
technisches know how und lässt sich
überhaupt an die herstellung und an die
an die leute die diese an transportieren
müssen und errichten müssen stellt die
müssen ja auch erst einmal gefunden
werden
um in die gänge zu kommen gibt es ein
paar mögliche maßnahmen die sehr
kurzfristig wirken können das werde ich
mir jetzt als nicht als erstes aber doch
als übernächstes schnell noch mal
anschauen inwieweit sie auf der länder
ebene oder auf der bundesebene
realisierbar sind aber es gibt
eigentlich immer flächen die schon
ausgewiesen sind die durch andere
schutzgüter gesperrt sind und da kann
man vielleicht kurzfristigen effekt
erzielen und so eine art bremse oder
blockade zu lösen
das ist aber nur der erste schritt und
in wahrheit ein trippelschritt sondern
die systemische veränderungen die im
koalitionsvertrag beschrieben sind die
also von dem gedanken der damalige nicht
selbstverständlich ist ausgehen dass
wenn wir uns von atom kohle und dann
perspektivisch in den 30er jahren noch
von den gaskraftwerken irgendwann
verabschieden die erneuerbaren
versorgungssicherheit also
sicherheitsrelevant sind gewährleisten
müssen der hat natürlich einfluss auf
andere schutzgüter und die werden dann
sorgsam ausdiskutiert werden müssen also
die kurzfristigen maßnahmen schaue ich
mir jetzt kurzfristig an die
längerfristigen und dann aber wirklich
wirksam müssen denke ich im ersten jahr
gefunden verabschiedet und auch
beschlossen werden herr dr
meine frage an herrn scholz auch in den
glücklichen vize kanzler
die frage von herrn rinke zum deutsch
polnischen verhältnis wenn ich richtig
sehe war der letzte besuch eines
deutschen regierungsmitglieds in
warschau des geschäftsführenden
innenminister seehofers sie woher der
der polnischen regierung unterstützung
solidarität für ihre umstritten ist
verhalten an der grenze zu weißrussland
ausgedruckt hat die polnische regierung
damit rechnen dass sich diese haltung
der bundesregierung unter ihrer führung
fortsetzen oder wird wollte es war auch
andere akzente geben
es ist die
regierung weißrusslands der dortige
regierungschef der
keine legitimation dem eigenen volk hat
der hat mit
seiner politik im hinblick auf die
flüchtlinge versucht hat
einfluss auf europa zu nehmen und ich
finde es ist nicht richtig wenn wir dann
weiter weg vom japanischen grenze zu
laos diejenigen sind die jetzt nicht das
klar zum ausdruck bringen worum es geht
das muss ein ende finden
das ist so wichtig dass europa weit
reichende strikt der entscheidung
getroffen hat denn hinblick auf
sanktionen
und dass wir alles dafür tun dass
fluglinien die weiter mit dem schicksal
von menschen
geschäfte machen die nach belarus
transportieren damit rechnen müssen dass
für sie konsequenzen hat in hinblick auf
ihre geschäftstätigkeit ihre flug
möglichkeit das gilt auch für die
flughäfen und die regionen von denen das
ausgeht darüber hat europa darüber
deutschland sehr klare gespräche geführt
und sie sehen ja auch dass das große
wirkung gehabt hat wir sehen auch
richtigerweise dass es jetzt
rücktransporte gibt von vielen wieder
zurückkehren was ich auch richtig findet
was auch notwendig ist und deshalb
glaube ich muss man schon anerkennen
dass polen dort eine schwierige aufgabe
hat und eine große große herausforderung
und da empfehlen sich nicht
kommentare von weiter weg
dann wechsle ich noch mal
gefreut dass wir ein paar fotos
dann vor kollegin vorne links genau ins
la von derzeit ich habe noch eine frage
zu ihrem umgang mit der klimakrise er
habe von ihnen wüsste ich gerne wann man
ihre ersten erfolge messen kann und
woran man die messen soll
von ihnen würde ich gerne wann es das
erste mal zu konflikten kommen wird bei
diesem großen thema viel verkehr viele
klima in der verkehrspolitik reicht das
was die koalition beschlossen hat bei
weitem nicht da schaut sie werden sich
karton dass man jetzt schon die dritte
frage
umgeht
die letzte habe ich nicht verstanden
aber das glaube ich
natürlich gibt es ein paar maßnahmen
haben bei der letzten frage beantwortet
habe ja schon gesagt die
ungefähre wirksam sind in dem sinne
erfolgreich sein können die betrifft im
übrigen nicht nur den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien sondern
die förderung von wasserstoff produktion
beispielsweise oder auch fördermaßnahmen
die dann in industriellen prozessen aber
auch für die wirtschaft insgesamt
den weg bahnen
letztlich denke ich aber dass wir wenn
wir ehrlich sind
in einem rückstand anfang
und diesen rückstand
die ersten anderthalb zwei jahren mit
uns herumschleppen werden und dass sich
wirklich strukturelle veränderungen auf
die kommt es ja an also nicht die
symbolischen punkte oder symbolisch
punkte ist falsch aber die kurzfristigen
geländegewinne als
als monstranz vor uns hertragen sondern
tatsächlich die strukturellen weichen so
stellen dass wir die grundsätzliche
veränderung auch schaffen ich bin ja
nicht nur klimaschutzminister waren
wirtschaftsminister und die idee beides
zusammen zu verbinden also die
wirtschaftliche prosperität die sozial
liberale marktwirtschaft mit einer neuen
ökologischen komponente in eine neue
ordnung zu bringen die ist ja die
eigentliche stärke also nicht der
klimaschutz hat ein paar erfolge gegen
das wirtschaftliche system wenn das
wirtschaftliche system insgesamt wird so
reformiert das wachstum und klimaschutz
sich organisch miteinander verbinden
dafür die gesetze zu machen dafür die
ordnungspolitischen leitplanken neu zu
justieren dafür die förderprogramme
auszurichten das ist die eigentliche
aufgabe und die gis kann sein dass sie
das erste jahr vor allem
gesetzgeberische wirksam ist um dann
umso stärker in die gänge zu kommen also
lange rede kurzer sinn es wird
sicherlich einige sehr schnell zu
ergreifende konkrete schritte geben aber
die wirksamkeit wird sich denke ich vor
allem im ersten im zweiten und einem
dritten jahr entfalten können
frau henzler ich verstehe das
bundesministerium der finanzen als ein
ermöglichung ministerium das heißt die
aufgabe in den nächsten vier jahren wird
es sein zu ermöglichen dass die
öffentlichen vorhaben für den
klimaschutz als auch die privaten
transformations- aufgaben realisiert
werden können insbesondere im bereich
der mobilität haben wir uns
außerordentlich ehrgeizige ziele gesetzt
etwa bei der
klimafreundlichen weiterentwicklung der
individuellen mobilität mit dem auto und
auch bei
der steigerung der leistungsfähigkeit
und attraktivität der schiene wenn
dieses programm das diese koalition sich
vorgenommen hat realisiert worden seien
wird dann werden wir in deutschland ein
mobiles aber auch wesentlich
klimafreundlichere lang sein und das zu
ermöglichen
das ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe unter
leisten auch wir die fdp unsere beiträge
insofern sehe ich keine konflikte danach
haben sie ja gefragt sondern ich sehe
gemeinsame anstrengungen und dort wo es
synchronisierungs bedarf gibt wo
kurzfristig ziele gegeneinander stehen
haben wir ja in den letzten wochen unter
beweis gestellt dass wir in der lage
sind und diskret und professionell zu
verständigen
dann wir haben noch genau fünf minuten
wir versuchen mal wird da kommen herr
papa ist danach verlief
aber was ja
ich habe eine frage
us-finanzminister
erlitten sie haben gerade gesagt
dass die
bundesregierung die neue bundesregierung
die stabilität eintreten wird aber in
vielen länder südeuropas heißt eine
große sorge dass deutschland mit ihnen
als finanzminister zu der sparpolitik
des vergangenen jahrzehntes zurückkehren
wird und die notwendige reform des
europäischen stabilitätspaktes bremsen
wird sind diese sorten europäischen
partner berechtigt und wie können sie zu
stellen
die bundesrepublik deutschland wird in
europa auf stabilität achten und
gleichzeitig ermöglichen dass
investitionen in
wettbewerbsfähigkeit freigesetzt werden
für uns ist dabei ein orientierungspunkt
die beeindruckende und erfolgreiche
politik der griechischen regierung
es ist dort in der letzten zeit gelungen
mit der beeindruckenden reformmaßnahmen
die griechische volkswirtschaft auf
einen neuen erfolgskurs zu bringen das
muss umgekehrt für deutschland sogar
anspruch sein ähnlich ambitioniert zu
werden wie die griechische innenpolitik
es ist und insofern freue ich mich auf
die nächsten gelegenheiten in athen mit
dem dortigen regierungschef und meinem
amtskollegen
die gespräche die wir in der
vergangenheit auch schon geführt haben
in guten klima und einvernehmen
fortzusetzen
denn vw fans
jetzt danke meine frage richtet sich an
den künftigen wirtschaftsminister herwig
sie sind ja auch für konjunkturprognosen
und die wirtschaftliche verfassung als
eines der führenden globalen länder
verantwortlich gemessen an der
wirtschaftskraft wie sehen sie denn ihr
verhältnis zur wirtschaft mit blick auf
die klimapolitischen umstellungen die
sie vorhaben will ich die da ein partner
muss die wirtschaft sehen sie dass die
wirtschaft weiter prosperiert oder main
7 die zumutungen werden da er auch mal
einen dämpfer
ich hoffe dass es umgekehrt ist dass das
dass die wirtschaft diese regierung und
auch das wirtschaftsministerium als
partner sieht und begreift für mich kann
ich das natürlich sagen unterschreiben
und unterstreichen so haben wir schon
die letzten jahre
auch in der position agiert
wir haben jetzt eben oder ich habe eben
gesagt was der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien an gesellschaftlichen debatten
nach sich ziehen wird oder welche sie
begleiten werden umgekehrt geht die
geschichte natürlich auch was für eine
riesen chance an innovation an wachstum
anmerken die sich auftut wenn wir diesen
weg gehen wenn wir es schaffen
die technik der zukunft die effizienzen
der zukunft die
die industrie der zukunft hier in europa
und hier in deutschland nach vorne zu
bringen und es war ja schon den letzten
jahren zu sehen dass die wirtschaft
häufig durch ihre
durch ein ihre organisation vertreten
aber selbst auch in den akteuren genau
das will dass sie dass sie darauf warten
dass die investitions unterstützung
freigegeben werden dass die regulierung
nachzieht ich glaube also dass die idee
die wirtschaft müsste zu irgendwas
gezwungen überredet oder genötigt zu
werden völlig an der wirklichkeit vorbei
geht die bereitschaft ist ja da der
wunsch diesen nächsten wachstumsschritt
zu gehen der ist greifbar sagen alle
auch in den industriellen bereichen an
die man nicht sofort denkt bis zur
zementindustrie dass da konzepte da sind
und jetzt wird die politische
unterstützung
folgen beziehungsweise beides
zusammenbringen und bei allen zumutungen
ist nichts zu tun nicht zu handeln aus
der sozialen marktwirtschaft eine
ökosoziale marktwirtschaft zu machen
wäre tatsächlich der größere fehler also
so schwer es wert wir können auch
unglaublich erfolgreich sein und haben
viel zu gewinnen alle miteinander
dann sind wir leider am ende
angelangt don quichotte es nicht mehr
dann hat er habe ich jetzt das
schlusswort bekommen schutz das tut mir
leid aber wir können ja jederzeit
wiederkommen danke für den besuch in der
bundespressekonferenz danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und pardon das finde ich
alle fragen geschafft haben